et maquettes avec nous bravo ma chérie
attend que tu as a bien un qui est
inquiétant c'est bon emma c'est ma
chérie attend maintenant c'est mon but
mais ça va ma chérie d'amour très très
content de te voir ça va mon but est
magnifique c'est quoi cette robe de
folie latin c'est quoi c'est assez
nouveau pas nouveau elle est magnifique
et et mac et la gagnante de the wall et
[Applaudissements]
rappelle parce que on s'est eu au
téléphone on était venu me voir et tu
m'avais dit j'ai un secret je vais faire
de vos skis d'eau pour venir mettre le
micro des mains du shérif on va voir la
victoire des mâts dans ce volet ce qui
dit on va en parler avec elle elle est
énervée après gilles verdez et mathieu
de l'envoi non arrivé en tête des votes
du public la grande gagnante de la
cinquième saison 2 de the voice qui tu
es
emma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maquettes avec nous emma qu'elle
gagne et chevreuils skid franchement je
suis hyper fier de toi tu as été
exceptionnel or pendant son audition à
la vedette à chanter une chanson que tu
adores sais je suis malade de serge lama
salat eu la chance tout le temps je sais
ouais mais tu l'a chanté tout le temps
on voit tes potes étaient venus à la
maison pendant toi je suis plus voilà
les venues moi l'idéal a passé il ya
deux ans un petit moment avec moi et
c'est vrai que tu lui as chanté tout le
temps un défaut a été comme ça je dis
que tu vas mourir je serais mal à ce que
tu veux manger
l'intérêt mais elle elle kiffe cette
chanson est tous les côtes s'était
retourné mais tu as choisi de rejoindre
l'équipe de soprano c'était le 19
octobre 2018 regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux jours
sauterel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors j'avais déjà fait mon choix a dit
et ont chassé son temps
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on ne sait jamais j'avais le trac
pendant les auditions pas dans son
audition ah ouais un peu bon t'as pas
papa est un coach et moi papa et maman
ton coach et ouais oui surtout que
l'équipe
vraiment elle est formidable ces
équipes-là de the voice un ouais ouais
c'est vrai que sur super nikos il était
super oui et alors alors tu étais que
soprano et ensuite le 23 novembre tu
faisais le battle avec marié enzo vous
avez interprété tous les cris les sos de
daniel balavoine
regardez
[Musique]
nos droits
c'est que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ensuite donc là après tu as été
repêché par jennifer a été repêché par
jennifer alors ce boys qui sait ce que
vous avez aimé ou pas et est ce que vous
êtes heureux de la victoire des mavs dit
ladd et rich ce que vous regardez la
régie ce nom-là pas la télé toujours ou
pas si je veux télé mais je voyais en
juin sterela ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai j'avais gagné évidemment
c'était le live il était fort je vous ai
vu les deux c'est à fondre à et nous
aussi on est à fond dedans avec mathieu
on a dansé mais du whitney houston noah
mais du whitney à l'aller oui alors
valérie bas moi vous vous ai dit que
cette année pour moi la scène the voice
qui n'a pris le pas sur de voice pour
moi c'était la saison de voice kid avec
en plus soprano et amel bent mois pour
moi ils ont fait une entrée formidable
dans cette émission et je suis c'était
ma petite chouchoute emma je laime
l'adorent et j'étais très très très
heureuse que social qui gagne alors elle
a chanté à haguenau fille de whitney
houston sur dj rien n'est pas la peine
de me demander quand elle avait chanté
deux chansons steinbach en rien j'ai
rien fait rien et un stade à ce qu'elle
dit tout le temps
regardez
[Musique]
on
et
oh
[Musique]
les maquettes avec nous
oui c'est un bilan positif pour deux
boys qui doutent de la programmation à
la rentrée parce que c'est la première
fois que tf1 prochain verra mission
aurait t et puis évidemment big up à
amel bent qui apporte surtout une chose
c'est que ces huit semaines est ni trop
court ni trop long c'est juste parfait
et bravo à toi tu as un talent
formidable rc je trouve qu'il fait très
bonne émission
oui gilles verdez emma est admirable
formidable mais ça n'enlève rien à ma
détestation de l'émission là oui ce sont
des enfants qui sont exploitées utilisé
par la descente exploiter bat s voilà ce
qu'aurait on a donc utilisé utilisé on
t'a fait voilà on t'a fait chanter
soulac servir à toi non parce que je me
suis amusé c'est toi qui a voulu faire
ce vol ce qui ne s'est même pas tes
parents je crois qu'ils ont inscrits
c'est toi qui est bien mais justement
c'est mon coup de gueule bah c'est ça
alors c'est quoi
pas contre toi mathieu hamon avait déjà
des prompteurs alors que c'est
totalement faux barahona des prompteurs
à l'émission et et puis c'est pas les
parents qui force c'était mon rêve
depuis tout petit de participer à ce
qu'ils aient donc et bim
alors
voilà c'est là on n'aime pas de 7 à 70
minutes à l'image de la bêtise mais
c'est à 10 mois et il dit que des
bêtises mais franchement je la dois à
ben je te répondre très très bon c'est
mon émission et mes émotions mais juste
dire quelque chose c'est que
contrairement aux tout petits camarades
si je n'aime pas cette émission c'est
justement parce que je pense aux enfants
et à toi je pense que je pense que les
plus beaux rêves sont ceux que l'on
construit non pas ce qu'on obtient et je
m'inquiète juste pour la suite parce que
je connais trop la télévision pour
savoir qu'on te mets dans la lumière
et puis ensuite une fois que les
recettes sont en fait on a tendance à
oublier les gens je veux juste que ça ne
fasse pas de mal plus tard comme voilà
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit cela et c'est
pour ça que je l'aï je me fous des
autres émissions télé crochet mais
contrairement à ce qu'on pense j'aime
beaucoup les enfants et j'ai peur pour
eux c'est pour ça que j'avais dit ça
alors il ya eu une petite polémique sur
emma aussi et là là là c'est mon coup de
gueule moi et ma je te connais depuis
très très longtemps dans les yeux d'emma
on sait que tu es time à une maladie
voilà depuis nombreuses années et que tu
perds la vue petit à petit on se bat
pour toi et tes parents donnent tout
pour toi
depuis le début et ton père et ta mère
il faut un travail exceptionnel avec
leur association les beaux yeux d'emma
chez la chance d'être le parrain de
cette association avec jean pierre
foucault et c'est vrai que je te connais
depuis des années et c'était ton rêve de
faire un voyage ce kid et a toujours
aimé chanter tu as toujours une voix
exceptionnelle et j'ai vu plein de gens
j'ai vu qu'elle certaines personnes
d'ailleurs c'est ton père qui m'a
demandé en plus manier vraiment syrie
donnent avec toi sur ce coup de gueule
parce que ton père ça l'à beaucoup
touché
ce qui s'est passé où il y avait des
gens sur les réseaux sociaux qu'ils
disaient et mal à gagner de nouveaux
risques it juste parce qu'elle est
malade n'importe quoi franchement je
sais plus si c'est un télé crochet ou
bien centre social voilà on a pu dire
des choses comme ça je me demande si
c'est la voix ou la maladie qui permet
gagner de wolski de cette année il faut
savoir vraiment là là c'est le genre de
tweets vraiment qu'on peut pas supporter
qui sont pas supportables pour les
parents d'emma et images ou leicester
redire ma chérie est à gagner parce que
tu as un talent exceptionnel on l'a
encore vu en live blanc
ce formidable et ton papa je n'ai vu
juste avant dans les loges
on m'a dit cyril à ce que tu peux en
parler bien sûr mais tu sais que tu es
un énorme bisou et toi tu sais que tu as
gagné parce que tu es formidable bas si
j'y suis c'est vrai que c'est pas grâce
à ma maladie que tu gagnes bah c'est sûr
c'est sûr mais ils se sont pas dit quand
ils ont voté un bain parce qu'elle est
malade donc du coup je vais voter j'ai
de la peine pour elle m'a bien sûr et
puis les coachs au départ quand il se
retourne et il se retourne et les quatre
parce que tu avais une voix
exceptionnelle
ça arrive à capter il savait pas ce que
tu faisais donc ils se sont retournés
juste parce que tu avais une voix
exceptionnelle et les quatre coaches je
te voulait dans leur équipe
c'est vrai ou pas oui pardon voilà si
réussi pourquoi il faut protéger pardon
si les enfants de la télévision et de ce
monde qui est si cruel quand on voit des
maîtres ddd twitter pour une jeune fille
ça peut être une petite recommend ça
peut être très violent très dur alors
s'épaulant durcir comme ça peut la faire
tomber ces sites sur mes inquiétudes
mois voilà lorsque c'est horrible du
christ parce que j'ai c'est que c'est
faux parce que tu es fort toi tu vis des
choses mais moi j'ai bien aimé cette
émission où les enfants il chante comme
ça est la voie qu'elle a elle ment pas
là c'est pas une question de maladie ce
qu'on vient de voir sur la scène
et puis pourquoi il faudrait attendre
pour vivre sa vie aveu la vie maintenant
sa vie à me chanter elle veut faire les
choses maintenant faudrait toujours
attendre attendre attendre attendre tu
vis ta vie aujourd'hui thonon location
sur terre c'est pas un cdi à la cave il
s'agit maintenant le scénario
[Musique]
elle a même dit qu'elle voudrait le
faire
comment expliquer ce qu'est ce tu es
belle saison je vous le dis je vois
plein de gens plein de téléspectateurs
qui me dit the wall sreet c'était la
plus belle saison cette année on a adoré
je pense que le jury était
exceptionnelle vraiment je pense qu'ils
ont là un jury je pense qu'il faut pas
qu'ils changent d'année prochaine
il y avait des candidats exceptionnels
dont emma et bien d'autres qui ont été
très très bon et franchement alors jouer
on voit j'aurais convoi le duo que tu as
fait avec jennifer survient on s'aime de
slimane bayard je fais plein de bisous
parce que il m'a envoyé un petit message
sur instagram team slimane et l embrasse
fort aussi
ouais c'est son tuyau avec vite en ce
moment chaud comme how dessus ouais je
chante avec vital à mercredi avec vita
oui elle avait besoin d'une grande voile
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
la journée où je suis en train de
répéter dans la loge tout à l'heure j'ai
une pêche l'habitude d'acheter ou pas
aujourd'hui jeanne un petit bout on va
d'abord regarder une enfant 53e assez
bas comme ailleurs est moche c'est comme
ma petite soeur vraiment ça tous les
deux et vous demande de chanter la
chanson etc slimane et évita
[Musique]
mais
a même été
j'en suis pas encore là moi j'en suis
qu'au début
[Rires]
[Musique]
dans note le temps d'un droit
elle écrit sèche c'est là qu'il faut la
lui
[Musique]
à lévis
j'adore votre vie
on chauffe
oh
[Musique]
je suis fou d'emma voilà je vous le dis
à bientôt et mature tu vas où passe un
petit où on fasse roche 3 4 jours de
vacances ensemble cet été
oui c'est fait allez allez ta place je
viens aussi moi c'est un amour et je
vous le dis on rigole grave qu'on tourne
avec elle n'a pas rigolé franchement
d'arrigoni des oufs larigaudrie de ouf
et je laime très très fort je suis
tellement fière de toi qui savait quoi
la suite m'attends à redon la suite soit
tu vas faire quoi là alors quand on
gagne ce débat parce qu après je fasse
quoi alors tu as gagné quoi un risque
bien trop fait un bac s est pas encore
voilà ce qu'il faut faire les gravures
des six d'accord il faut qu'il mette
tournons tous ah ouais mais après je
suis fait refaire un album j'espère je
chéris en tout cas on sera toujours là
porter sa voix toujours là pour toi